je crois profondément en la
perfectibilité des êtres humains
on pourra enfin réaliser notre potentiel
si nous sommes au meilleur de nous mêmes
aucun problème ne peut nous résister on
peut guérir toutes les maladies ou
vaincre la faim dans le monde
imaginez ce que ça représente pour les
droits de l'homme les possibilités sont
infimes
[Applaudissements]
vous avez réglé 20 dollars 86 et le
montant de la facture était de 20 68
c'est moi qui vous remercie
[Musique]
un boulot à cet organe doit rien
point coup profite de la soirée et
surtout éclate toi tu es à ceux ci
comment ça va c'est jared qui va te
former moi aussi c'était dur les
premières semaines j'ai vraiment ramé
crois moi tu dis si tu devrais bien
m'avoir au boulot de temps en temps
qu'ils vont croire que le jir nettoyer
les toilettes
tu es vraiment apprécié une employée
exemplaire pas tout de suite eu une
bonne moyenne
on doit jamais sur le campus le week-end
mon père à une crise c'est pour ça que
j'ai dû aller était ma mère ces liens se
sclérose en plaques
j'ai étudié de près l'assurance médicale
de tes parents et je crois que j'ai une
idée je me demandais si les parents ne
pourraient bénéficier notre mutuelle
je vais vous dire à quel point c'est
important tu vous remercie d'avoir été
ma femme tu fais partie des heures cale
est tout ce qui compte pour toi conte
pronos elle n'est ici que depuis
quelques mois mais elle a déjà fait
forte impression
tu penses que ta conduite et pire ou
meilleure quand tu sais quand tu
observes j'ai actuellement une dizaine
de personnes qui parcourt le monde avec
ses caméras
tous les deux avant d'aller à l'aventuré
on s'amuse et on découvre et des trucs
et toi tu étais audacieuse et
enthousiaste et maintenant tu vis tout à
travers un film
[Musique]
je vais pas inventer pour ça c'est parce
que je voulais 6
ce que fait the circle il faut que ça
s'arrête
[Musique]
les données de tous les membres de ce
recueil sont analysés monétiser
ils pourront faire ce qu'il faudra on
était d'abord à toi
[Musique]
parce que savoir c'est bien
mais tout savoir c'est mieux
tu n'aurais pas quelque chose à nous
dire
the washing